happens.
Oh, this is stopped. Uh, it's
continuing. No, no.
Okay, guys. One second, guys.
Okay. Hello guys. Okay. Today's video I
want to really talk about something
really hard. It's something I call, you
know, I'm trying to steal everyone's
aura in the past. People actually can
help us. You know, for me, I think it's
just one initiative. I'm taking to for
them because may not know the solution
to a problem. You know, it's called PLP
principle as a protocol. You know, guys,
today's video is very important to me.
You know, it means something uh to me as
a child. Basically, someone called Mr.
Sim
basically Mr. Sim was a teacher of
French, you know, he was a good French
teacher. I love that man, you know. You
know, but no student, you know, it was a
first year school. We need to talk to
you about Mr. Mr. Mr. You know, you
know, I had to had to really look at him
like like him as he was. You know, you
have to find out, you know, why it was
that way. You know, it was strict in
class. It was it wasn't like hard
anything. It wasn't wasn't hurting
anyone physically, but he knew how the
system works. You know, he's telling us
about our lives. He talk he's teaching
he teach you, but you don't know he's
teaching you. You know, you know this
man
understand what was the problem. Mr.
Slim was a teacher was a teacher.
Teacher I loved, you know, I loved him
cuz he he was able to communicate
effectively to me and not to others but
in a more African way, you know, but it
was it was modest. It wasn't like pushy.
It was like you do it or not, you fail,
you know. Okay. Mr. Lim was a a French
teacher. I was 9 years old. No, I was 9
years. 9 years. I got to I was 11 years
old. I got to French class.
had a French but he didn't expect
English you know in a French class speak
French you know Mr. said you know not
who got that but I understood that very
well you know Mr. Selim understood that
French was from French class only you
know you know you're in French with him
you French no one of English can ask in
French if you want to hear English you
don't say anything in English you know
Mr.
wasn't powerful. He couldn't make the
law couldn't change anything in school.
Yeah. He will show a puppet to them as
well like me. I'm a to the
to them like myself you know they don't
know the poet school French but you know
English but for me I am not the puppet
no more I am I I am transcending the
cycle of depression now may not be me to
do it but I'm doing on his behalf you
know he may go forget never see his
video you know he may never find his
video may never see what this what I'm
doing for him you know here but Mr.
Thank you very much you know you know I
think about it I talk about it today is
you know the 14th of November 25 Mr.
Slim you know you are you are one of the
best teachers there you know whether you
know it or not you deserve you a gold
medal you know two gold medals for that
for that you know and why Mr. Slim you
know I g
in look your you know I'm going to do it
for you and teachers like you you know
you know you know
so you know birectional in you know this
is a great thing to understand you know
Mr. Slim didn't know everything. He
doesn't know everything. But he was able
to communicate birectionally. That's two
languages. You know, he can go to French
class and mingle. You know, you can go
to English class and mingle. You know,
was able to navigate the system, you
know, much better than me at the time. I
can go French at the time, you know. But
he's able to relay good communication
very well guys able to even speak pigeon
or like African like the broken English
or the slang in UK and talk for you go
through everywhere. You can't go to
neighborhood. You can't go to the
accepted guys. You know if you speak a
street talk only can't go through the
parliament do for processes do legal
actions you know things are very formal
you know you can't do it you know it's
no way. So that's why birectional
learning is very important. What does it
mean to you? You know, you speak
English, I speak French. You know, you
can still communicate with one language.
You know, English, you know, if you I
speak French, you speak English. You
want to speak French.
This this really means a lot to me,
guys. You know, I'm not doing it for the
crowd. I'm doing it because it's
mother's honest, you know. I want to
think um think of me, you know, you
know, actually making something better
for everyone else, you know. I want to
think of him me as he succeeded, you
know.
You may not know what this means to me,
but you know if you only know one
language, it doesn't mean anything to
me. I mean policing
framework, you know, you know, uh if if
anybody if I'm teaching a language in
French, you know, any language, you
guys, if I put a sign in front of my
door, guys, I'm not joking. If I put a
sign, no English, only French, you know,
only French. If you enter that class,
that room you know that environment I
don't want to hear anyone children adult
a word of English you know if I put only
if I put only English you're coming to
only English if I put only French guys
not a word of English you're like in
that be out in a second
guys I'm doing it for everyone that want
to learn you know French you know or
English or
true positive true negative
through positive force matrix you know
the birectional learning clothes you
know these are the things that force the
need to work you know direct the
evolution direction
in kinematics probably you know if you
don't know you can ask in French you can
take your phone trust me in French
as long as you never hear you English
guys
you know
I'm doing this you know if if I sign on
my only in French guys don't even utter
a word of it in French you know can find
a slang one of it I don't really care it
sounds
it's called the French something called
a French line you know guys you know
please please for the sake of humanity
for the sake of humanity when I'm
teaching anyone adults you the children
I don't care
Don't bring your child into my class.
Basically all the various I about
structure you know if the design of the
structure is rigid is not flexible
enough you know or my classrooms are
have um ways go like you know English
place French place guys I don't see
anyone in English section uh or English
time speaking French you know when the
time was up second of it
uh
in red bridge
take the test
compre you know that compreh
you you
I hope this video you found this video
helpful and I hope I hope it brings you
peace of mind.
My name is Nambi Michaela
and I wish you
a Halloween if you get it in time. Uh a
merry Christmas and a happy rest of your
life.
But all be
thank you very much.